ma question s'adresse à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre chargé des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
madame la ministre les formalités
administratives sont des contraintes
nécessaires mais qui pèsent sur
l'activité de nos TPE et PME
pour faciliter la création et le
développement d'entreprises notre
majorité a décidé en 2019 dans la loi
pacte de rassembler les 7 réseaux épars
de centre de formalités des entreprises
en un seul guichet unique
ce guichet unique doit permettre à
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur forme juridique et leur domaine
d'activité de déclarer en ligne toutes
les formalités auprès des différents
organismes que ce soit les services
fiscaux sociaux ou encore l'Insee
création modifications dépôt des contes
annuels ou cessation d'activité tout
doit se faire en ligne sur un même site
cette dématérialisation pilotée par
l'INPI est une bonne chose pour notre
économie alors que les records de
création d'entreprise s'enchaînent
toutefois madame la ministre tous les
acteurs nous font part depuis des
semaines de Lourdes dysfonctionnements
PagesBlanches impossibilité d'utiliser
certaines fonctionnalités et bug
paralyse la plateforme et contraignent
de nombreuses PME TPE et ETI à repousser
leurs démarches en bolisant notre
économie il y a quelques semaines vous
avez activé dans l'urgence d'une
procédure de secours en rouvrent
temporairement la plateforme Infogreffe
pour quelques formalités
certains actes peuvent ainsi aussi être
réalisés par voie papier auprès des
greffes compétents nous renvoyons 15 ans
en arrière
la réouverture de cette plateforme est
partielle et ne permet pas de remédier
complètement à ses défaillances
quasiment deux mois après l'ouverture du
guichet unique c'est carences
ininterrompues sont difficilement
compréhensibles ainsi madame la ministre
que comptez-vous faire